okay now that we've had a chance to sort
of calm down from that
wild jimmy from philly call let's go
back to the phone lines at 617-830-4750
and see what's on people's minds
starting with our caller from the 928
area code who is calling today from 928
hey david this is sean hey sean what's
going on
um i'm just curious why is no one
talking about
um so i know it's a law that says
election day has to be
the second tuesday or whatever well i
think the way it's technically it's the
first tuesday
after the first monday so it couldn't be
the first of the month i guess is the
idea
why why is no one talking about since
that's a law why don't they just
extend like i've always questioned why
it's not on a weekend anyway
so why don't they talk about making it
you know
the week instead of just one day okay
well people do talk about
people do talk about either making
election day a federal holiday
although it's unclear the net benefit of
that because a lot of people work on
holidays anyway it would just kind of
like change who's able to vote there's a
discussion about voting on the we
all of these things have been discussed
but it's very difficult to do it
certainly isn't going to happen between
now and november but
is there some particular reason why you
think this time around it should be done
well because of the pandemic right you
could spread out you could say
you know if you have a last name a to d
gotta go on tuesday you don't eat a day
wednesday whatever so the easier way to
do it legally would be instead of
extending voting to multiple days
you would just start every day so
right now early voting in states that
have it it's usually only a few polling
places and it's limited hours the way to
do what you're suggesting
i think sean would be on october 27th we
say
polls open today and they will be open
through the end of november 3rd and give
right so start with
a full day early voting in all polling
places
that would probably be the simplest way
to do it legally and logistically
right so instead of this stupid argument
about mailing
ballots and fraud that's not going to
happen why don't the states just start
talking about that i haven't heard
anything about that yeah i mean it's not
being discussed because i just don't
think
most governors are going to do it and
logistically to keep polling places you
know
people volunteer months ahead of time to
do poll work
on one day if you're going to say we're
now going to have seven days of poll
work
i it is a logistical nightmare and i get
why it's not being discussed but as an
idea i think it's a good one
all right well you don't think it's
going to happen ever
that we send election data more than one
day
i don't think it's going to happen this
year but i'm open to it you know who can
say what will happen in the future
right so basically democrats would have
to get
have two-thirds of the vote right in the
senate in order for that law to actually
pass
well it would probably be easier to do
it at the state level we're governor
because governors control early voting
so you don't even have to do it in the
senate
okay
all right thanks dave okay thank you
appreciate it people are thinking
that's good i like to see that